the Five Nights at Freddy's movie is
finally here bringing the well-loved
horrror video game series to movie goers
in live action are ex users smitten or
have they decided to switch the lights
off at Freddy Fazbear's pizza and never
come back Five Nights at Freddy's
centers on Mike Schmidt who bites off a
bit more than he can chew when he takes
a job as a security guard at Freddy
Fazbear's Pizza where things get hair
raising after dark officer have you met
them
yet M
who them though the Blum House uctions
effort tries to Faithfully adapt the
game Universe while providing a solid
horror experience so far it's not doing
well with critics at the time of this
video the film has only a 27% critics
score on Rotten Tomatoes however when it
comes to a franchise with such an
intense cult following the critics
reviews only mean so much as Five Nights
at Freddy's launches its cinematic run
fans on a the platform formerly known as
Twitter are sharing their thoughts on
the long awaited feature while reactions
have run the gamut X users have been
generally kinder to the film than
critics have one user expressed a
similar view to many fans when they
wrote incredible adaptation for what it
was and the budget they had another user
was especially elated about the film and
can't wait to rewatch it they gushed
just watched Five Nights at Freddy's and
the movie was absolutely perfect for me
people laughed got jump scared and
enjoyed it in my cinema the movie got
created especially for fans it shows and
I'm so glad about it another user who
was completely unaware of the franchise
before the film's release came away
saying I knew nothing of FNAF and I
enjoyed it still plenty of other viewers
and Fred Fanatics have unsurprisingly
asserted that you'll have more fun if
you're a fan of the franchise one user
tweeted it's a fun enough time if you
like the games and the fan theories good
but in a goofy way there are ghost
children possessing giant
robots thanks for the heads up keeping
the positivity rolling and other user
expressed their love for the film and
all caps and praise a creative team that
worked to bring it to life in part they
wrote congrats to everyone who worked on
it they did an amazing job as for
another ecstatic user they gave Five
Nights at Freddy's a score of 10 out of
10 in wrot in all caps literally shaking
with excitement from the movie however
despite a good portion of Five Nights at
Freddy's we were showering the movie
with praise others are expressing some
Hang-Ups much of the debate around the
film thus far has focused on whether or
not it's effective as a horror movie
which is undoubtedly an important
question for any entry in the genre one
user who delved into this question in
their Mini review claimed that Five
Nights at Freddy's isn't too bad as a
horror movie overall but is lacking in
the gore Department in a similar vein
another user recommended that fans see
the movie but added overall all I just
thought it was underwhelming but the
animatronics were very cool I just wish
we saw more of them LOL while many find
the lack of horror to be a strike
against Five Nights at Freddy's some
don't have as much of an issue with it
one user wrote I was expecting lots of
jump scares but to my positive surprise
I got a horror drama with an interesting
plot and even some heartwarming moments
another user agreed and tweeted false
flat is a horror movie but triumphs as a
movie made for FNAF fans still plenty of
fans think that an R-rated cut of the
movie would have worked much better in
fact it wouldn't be out of line to say
that most horror fans prefer R-rated
entries in general since many of the
features that Define horror movies
specifically Gore and profanity can't be
exploited to their fullest potential
otherwise for those curious about
putting these movie goer assessments to
the test Five Nights at Freddy's will
play in theaters and on the peacock
streaming service
[Music]
simultaneously